[Musique]
cannelle Heidi ou encore Joey ne sont
pas là que pour manger des légumes s'ils
sont présents aujourd'hui c'est pour
accompagner quatre enfants de l'Institut
médico-éducatifs le Castel de gazérant
alors tu as dit bonjour
[Musique]
Ombeline Sixtine Joseph et Killian se
rendent tous les vendredis dans cette
salle de Boissière l'école ils y sont
accueillis par Christiane de vie
éducatrice spécialisée mais ici sur ton
médiatrice animal elle met ses cochons
d'inde lapin et son chien à disposition
des enfants aujourd'hui on a commencé
par une petite séance de motricité avec
du découpage de légumes tomates
kiwi kiwi
non poivron ils ont aussi appris à
contrôler un peu leur gestes un geste
trop brusque pas faire fuir donc il faut
apprendre à oui je fais la statue je me
pose et du coup le lapin il va venir
manger il aura moins peur donc la
deuxième partie c'était la séance avec
avec SANCA on était sur la numération la
croix à compter 1 2
3 voilà c'est la 3
[Musique]
là c'est la fin de la séance du coup on
prend un petit temps où on se pose avec
les animaux on prend le temps de les
caresser de les laisser se déplacer un
petit peu comme ça on voit comment ça
bouge on peut toucher avec les mains on
peut toucher avec les pieds on peut les
poser sur le corps
comme Kylian qui aime beaucoup avoir le
cochon d'Inde en fin de séance sur son
ventre et passer les sources de blocage
améliorer sa communication faire le lien
avec les autres ou encore travailler
l'essence avec les différences de poils
ou de taille les séances sont pluriel et
se construisent en coopération avec les
éducatrices spécialisées du centre il y
a les enfants qui ont des peurs des
animaux et donc là avec Christian on va
vraiment travailler comment on peut
amorcer
d'avoir moins peur en fonction d'animal
comment on s'approche de l'animal
ensuite on a des enfants qui sont qui
n'ont pas connu
c'est vraiment un outil de média avec
eux pour voilà pour rentrer en relation
avec eux à travers l'animal pour pouvoir
leur apprendre
différentes manières de se tenir
christiane a lancé son association à
toute pâtes en 2021 elle et ses animaux
se sont formés à cette pratique il faut
pouvoir travailler et faire les choses
sérieusement en respectant aussi le
bien-être des animaux mais aussi les
personnes qu'on avec qui on va proposer
les séances pas faire n'importe quoi il
faut surtout les habitués à être
manipulés c'est surtout ça souvent la
crainte des animaux c'est voilà pouvoir
être malipulé pouvoir voilà
régulièrement les prendre leur faire
voir différents endroits à toutes pas de
se déplacent également dans les EHPAD
foyer d'accueil médicalisé ou encore
SESSAD une méthode complémentaire au
soin traditionnel qui offre de nombreux
bienfaits et ce n'est pas cinq cas qui
va s'en plaindre
[Musique]